make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so 45 years reading comic books and
I learned new things everyday somebody
asked the question if I would make a too
powerful for the Marvel movies video on
the Goblin force and my first thought
was like the Green Goblin like why would
he be too powerful for Marvel movies
like it's it's literally just a crazy
guy with a Green Goblin I guess that's
not even remotely too powerful for the
for the MCU I was like okay let's do a
little pokin let's do a little bit of
research okay
back in 1998 Marvel had this series
called mutant X which originally was
supposed to be a 12 part limited series
apparently it was exceedingly popular
and it stretched out to 35 issues before
it got cancelled I never read it and I
didn't even know what existed I went
through a sort of reading and I hadn't
read the whole thing but I went through
and started reading it is actually kind
of cool stuff it's basically a different
take on the main Marvel Universe mama
had a lot of versions of like
quote-unquote the Ultimate Universe
before the Ultimate Universe like there
were a lot of variations of that like
you had earth 98 where heroes aged in
real time new Universal by unroot wasn't
it originally but Warren Ellis did an
updated version but that one was kind of
like an answer it was well really that
one came after the Ultimate Universe was
already formed but like that's kind of
an answer to the question of like real
world superheroes someone that so forth
but the Goblin force is this it's
interesting because Marvel kind of
explores the concept of it being
multiversal but doesn't really confirm
it so here's the thing the Goblin force
originates from Earth 1298
which is like this alternate universe
where essentially like Cyclops was taken
by the Shiar Empire um anyway things are
these are like totally shifted around
they're basically kind of kind of
reworked and it's kind of an interesting
scenario the way the Goblin force works
is that like in the beginning of that
what seems to be that universes creation
the Goblin force basically emerged as
kind of like this representation of like
all evil now the funny thing about this
is you can kind of extrapolate things
right so like the when the Goblin force
would it really sort of like making its
move right like when earth became a
place whereby could house like life and
beings with powers and so on and so
forth now the Phoenix force looked to
bond itself to Jean Grey and Galactus
wanted to consume the earth as though
things were supposed to happen under
that normal circumstance the issue was
both beings basically ran into the
goblin force and the goblin force
consumed the Phoenix force and then
killed Galactus and it was kind of weird
because Galactus is a universal constant
right like Galactus is is not a
multiversal entity like Galactus is not
a multiversal threat he doesn't have
that kind of power but when it comes to
the Phoenix force the Phoenix is a
multiversal entity right like across the
haier multiverse is only one Phoenix and
while the Phoenix may appear in
different universes those are all just
kind of fact similes the Phoenix force
because while there is only one could
appear in like five hundred different
universes but it's all just one aspect
of the same Phoenix force as it was it's
kind of interesting because to have the
the goblin force to be powerful enough
to destroy even if it's only a facsimile
of the Phoenix force begs the question
is it as powerful is the Phoenix force
and that really that that's where things
kind of get hairy because the Phoenix
force is like any other being right
technically the Phoenix force is an
infinite source of energy and so it
stands to reason that if the Phoenix
force is an infinite source of energy
then all the facts similes are
infinitely powerful as well right I mean
it's only it's a finite amount of power
it's all I got a scale of 0 to 100 the
Phoenix force is that like a 90 and then
if it's split among if it's split in
half then like each of those have like
45 percent of the Dragons 50% of the
Phoenix force is like true power it
doesn't really work that way like it's
an infinite amount of power therefore it
can spread itself an infinite number of
times and then essentially have however
much power you know I like an infinite
amount of power even then it kind of
gets crazy because you're talking about
like the lifespan of the multiverse
right but like presumably the multiverse
will exist forever really so we're
supposed to but nonetheless it's one of
these weird things so you kind of have
to go with that and make the argument
that like the goblin force is infinitely
powerful and the reason why is because
in that story in mutant acts the goblin
force was destroyed by havoc the brother
of Cyclops when he absorbed the Nexus of
all realities now this is not to be
confused with the m'kraan crystal when
it comes to Marvel Comics you've got a
bunch of different access points for
like the multiverse right like
technically speaking the multiverse is
usually consistently shown to be like
something akin to a hallway of doors but
there's multiple ways to get into that
hallway of doors the Nexus of all
realities actually exists in the
Everglades it exists in Florida and it's
guarded by Man Thing that's where the
reasons why those who know fear burn at
the man-things touch is designed to
basically like safeguard the portal to
the multiverse or to the to the Nexus of
all realities what would happen is if
you pass through that nexus of all
realities you would literally just end
up in like this crazy kooky looking
place where you could follow these weird
paths and things like that and who knows
what universe you would end up with
that's how Howard the Duck ended up in
the main Marvel Universe is he came from
a universe where it was nothing but
animals who were like anthropomorphic
and could talk and then walking along
the pathway
fell off and then ended up in the name
our universe then you have the m'kraan
crystal which is more of a structured
version of the hallway of doors but a
hallway of doors nonetheless
can go into the negative zone and then
start popping out in different realities
from the negative zone since every
universe can tap into the negative zone
so you can leave the main Marvel
Universe go into the negative zone and
come out in the in the ultimate universe
it gets kind of crazy but the Nexus of
all realities is something you don't
really see dealt with all that often but
what havoc effectively did at least
after it was weird
the Beyonder saw what was going on with
the goblin force and then merged itself
for the goblin force and so basically
what you had was this insane force of
energy that just wanted to destroy
everything everywhere it went that had
the power of the Beyonder which was
hitherto unrivaled and then you had the
power of the Phoenix force bonded to it
and then presumably the the power cosmic
when it killed Galactus and then in turn
like it wanted to destroy the universe
and then of course destroy the
multiverse
the weird thing about this is that when
it came to the Beyonder that's really
where things begin to shift when it came
to the Beyonder if we're going with like
The Secret Wars 2 version which makes
sense because the Beyonder wasn't
changed until 2006 2007 with Brian
Michael Bendis is iluminati miniseries
so in 1998 the Beyonder was just like it
was still a remnant of like this
omniversal on indestructible immutable
force that was presumably more powerful
than the one above all or there's a very
lease of living tribunal and then when
you have that kind of bonded with like
the Phoenix force and the Goblin force
and all that kind of stuff then in turn
the Goblin force would have to become
multiversal which begs the question why
didn't they just leave the universe and
so when when this whole thing happens
havoc basically absorbs the Nexus of all
realities essentially he absorbs all the
energy of the multiverse and then
separates the Goblin force from Madeline
prior and then wipes the Goblin force
from existence in order to basically
defeat it you'd be talking about a being
of sufficient power that's equal to the
power of the multiverse and the only
beings that are out there who are that
powerful or the Beyonder from the main
Marvel Universe the molecule man Owen
Reese the beyonders themselves from the
Beyond realm the Limi tribunal and the
one above all and probably Abraxas those
are really the only beings that I could
I could see being powerful enough cuz
even Franklin Richards is only a
universal level Franklin Richards is not
multiverse alone
Matt Jim Jasper's could do it because I
mean he can you know manipulate reality
on any scale within a universal space he
just has to have a universe to
manipulate but where the character like
that being too powerful for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's actually a
caveat so in the original story when the
Goblin force first manifested and
started like trying to attack things it
took like a host of Celestials a huge
number of which basically died to
contain it to reduce its power and then
lock it away so technically speaking it
can be overcome by like sheer force
assuming the total number of power from
those various beings are equal to the
Goblin force itself and so when that
happened the Goblin forces power was
like drastically reduced it was powerful
enough to be able to just to consume the
Phoenix force but it wasn't really
powerful enough to do much else it
wasn't until to absorb the Phoenix force
that it was powerful enough to kill
Galactus and so so we have to kind of
assume the Phoenix in that universe was
not as powerful as like the main Marvel
Universe but when it did that and then
bonded itself with the Beyonder and then
bonded itself with Madalyn prior then
his powers amplified even further and so
what this basically means is that the
Goblin force on its own and it's in its
base form that is to say like assuming
that we go forward from the point when
the Celestials imprisoned it is not
astronomically powerful like it's not
this unbeatable immutable force but what
you would have to do is introduce
somebody into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that could effectively take it
out because the other all the heroes who
exist there would never be able to do it
on their own that it's not powerful
enough but you are talking about also
invoking like the Infinity stones and
the Infinity stones as far as I'm aware
we're never used in the Mutant X story
against the Goblin force they were new
and every user never referenced at least
in the the as ID like when I read it I
hadn't seen any reference to the
Infinity stones and so with the Infinity
stones that could probably be their
MacGuffin maybe their ability to like
destroy the Goblin force because if it
originates from the main Marvel Universe
that means or I guess from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's part and parcel
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe and it
can be destroyed that way and that's
what they would have to do they would
literally have to assemble the Infinity
Gauntlet use it and then wipe it out
wipe it from existence assuming that
doesn't work then you would have to
invoke the Living Tribunal and a Limi
tribunal I could have to be a trial just
like it always is right like the cosmic
entities and the various superheroes
would have to get together they'd have
to summon The Living Tribunal the
loading tribunal would show up they
would make their case and basically say
this being is astronomically powerful
and it's killing everything you have to
stop it most likely the Living Tribunal
would judge against the heroes and say
like the Goblin force originated with
the creation of this universe it's the
natural order of things
sorry about your luck and then the The
Living Tribunal would just leave if
that's the case everybody's doomed
aside from being a slide from the
Infinity Gauntlet being powerful enough
to pull it off everybody's screwed and
they're all gonna die but if the
Infinity Gauntlet is powerful enough and
it does harness the fundamental forces
of the universe presumably because the
Goblin force originates from the
universe
meaning that in a sense it originates
from the infinity stone since they're
basically the universe in physical form
then it could be destroyed by the gone
proper but again like a lot of stuff's
up in the air because is a very
ambiguous set of events like it's a very
ambiguous story because a goblin forces
left that universe it's not like the
Goblin force destroyed earth
you know 1298 and then went into the
multiverse and eventually met like the
main Marvel Universe and then like they
destroyed it with the Infinity Gauntlet
our answer would be done pretty simple
but like we don't have that it was
destroyed within the context of the
story and not everything in that story
was fully explored in terms of how it
matched up to like all the other things
that we know so again it's kind of a
murky situation again I kind of stick by
that if the Infinity Gauntlet is
assembled and is powerful enough it
could destroy the the Goblin force if
not then they're all basically screwed
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed that video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you